[Music]
amazing
[Applause]
Pepsi I might not be leaving I might
stay forever here's to all of you
fabulous ladies
[Music]
The Sounds why this is probably why
Giselle is single
no man wants to have sex with that
my intention for this trip that I keep
all of my edges yeah what is that big
old thing it looks like a penis thank
you
a food orgasm it came on my face
sing it who gonna be my porn star I'm in
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah lift that leg
they were trying to I want my money back
because ain't nobody to touch mine
I mean it's eight housewives in a
foreign country what can go wrong
Heather you talked about your
relationship with Whitney so like is
there an issue or not
you don't like me I'm like you cool
Porsche bye you all became friends and
two minutes later you and her husband
was David you stole somebody's man Jen
Shaw you knew she was lying she either
lied to me five minutes before she went
into the courtroom where she lied to the
judge if you were my friend but you told
everyone to have a fake marriage oh you
know what you he took out of pills your
brain is that cry you brought us me from
that raggedy [__] cause you're acting
like I didn't ride for you yeah I did it
I don't owe you anything for you to be
loyal to me as my [__] cousin you
chouting you fight two minutes hey give
me a hat that is fake
what if like one of the women tries to
frame me she's accusing us of larceny
hot sauce back not a green hoe and like
gets drugs from someone and puts it in
my bag you wanted me to go to jail
everyone's looking at me who's trying to
set me up have you ever seen that movie
with Claire Danes broke down palace keep
breathing I'm not wearing underwear this
is Rihanna not TV this is real
you guys just gave me my period thank
you does anybody have a tampon
who gets a period anymore it's so 1980.